[Music]
unwanted recommendation news boy just
[ __ ] just recommended Tiff's name her
toes the Concord saying that my second
toe it bends down and then he I would
have named the other one captain Jose Oh
gonzo gonzo Captain Hook from the mud
Michelle gonzo gonzo snow yet his nose
yeah no that one's perfect
Concord oh my gosh alright submitted by
Jackie Chan vs. mr. Miyagi well that's a
good look
twitch streamer Ninja is disgusted at
the platform after a porn stream was
promoted on his channel near me mixer
no no twitch on Twitter now move to
mixer yeah which I had never heard of I
don't even know these things anymore not
me neither
I heard about this porn was promoted on
yeah so ok this guy he's a fortnight
legend name ninja and he has over 14
million followers on Twitch how old is
he
you're a ninja right I only heard of him
because of the hole he's moving off
which name but I didn't know like
anything he's like the most popping
streamer like in the world like the
PewDiePie of which 20 years old dudes
gaming skills are [ __ ] crazy like you
could just watch how he plays and it's
like easy so since he left his um his
entire channels pretty much I goes on V
Channel and so twitch was testing out
this new feature where whenever someone
is offline they will have these
recommendations for the same type of
genre be puffed up on that zombie
channel page so somehow this porn stream
was pushed up to the top of like the
recommendation which means it was like
super trending at the moment Oh God so
it showed up on his channel oh it was
Japanese porn - see it's pixelated the
whole thing is Pixar Lena
we can show porn one twitch I didn't
know that so that happened right and
then ninja ended up posting on Twitter
that he's so disgusted and he's so sorry
and he posted this video with that as
you guys know I'm streaming on mixer now
my team and I have made sure that the
transition smooth super professional
obviously because it really hadn't been
me reason to you over the last couple of
days there have been some things have
been going on that you know we left side
they were kind of annoying little jabs
we felt like but didn't matter we wanted
to stay professional but now those you
don't know if you go to twitch.tv slash
ninja they advertise other channels they
don't do this for anyone else that's
offline by the oh just me there are also
other streamers who have signed with
other platforms who stream and channel
still remains the same you can see their
pods they don't promote other streams
you know from another promote other
popular channels but they do online
i'ma streaming for eight years to build
my brand to build that channel 14 and a
half million followers and they were
still using my channel to promote other
streamers
well now nor the port account that was
number one being recommended on my
channel and I have no say in any of this
stuff so this is like this is the line
this is the straw we're trying to get
the whole channel taking down to begin
with or at least not promote other
streamers and other channels on my brand
on my to cancel it so for anyone who saw
that for any ones whose kids apologize
I'm sorry that sucks dude brand you got
some petty [ __ ] over there I guess so
oh the real question is who is driving
the CEO of YouTube in the car enough so
twist who's driving
yeah almost makes it anyway oh yeah see
conspiracies good switch a CEO tweet it
out one our community comes to twitch
looking for it comes comes to Twitter
looking for live content to help ensure
they find great live channels we've been
experimenting with showing recommended
content across twitch including on
streamers pages that are offline
- oh this helps all streamers as it
creates new community connections
however the loot content that appeared
on the ninja offline channel page
grossly violates our Terms of Service
and we've permanently suspended the
account in question we have also
suspended these recommendations while we
investigate how this content came to be
promoted on a more personal note I
apologize want to apologize directly to
ninja that this happened it wasn't our
intent but it should not have happened
no excuses that makes sense but apology
I think sounds genuine
how did that happen but yeah how did
that happen so it was because there was
this it was artificially inflated like
the views of that stream was
artificially inflated which ended up
making it go to the top of the fortnight
recommendations oh just someone was
having a hacking time but who did it
with a candlestick in the library that's
a game it's called guess no it's I'm
saying it's called guess
yes clue you guys are right guess who
won it's like a whole road does he ever
be the game do you remember the
commercial for it and they all talk into
each other yeah yeah my didn't talk no I
remember being pissed that he didn't
talk could you see the commercial ah
[ __ ] and then all the commercials that
started saying oh yeah the cards do not
actually talk but yeah anyway so this
whole thing it's like huge in the
community in the streaming community the
fact that that porn was playing on
ninjas channel is so huge so it's a
crazy controversy thing here it is
pretty crazy because if it's just his
channel that was that they were
experiencing the whole recommendation
things on there just still trying to
farm out views
his subs and they don't want them to
leave man streamers make so much money
if I would have known I would have got
into video games back in the day wasn't
my thing I mean that's what what you're
doing now I mean yeah but like if I
could make like another like I don't
know tenth that whatever how much money
you get to put so many hours into it
though it's like a cut like a money per
per hour for time thing it's not like
passive income I mean I do like I know
one of the homies that does it makes
good money but he's uploading public an
hour footage like every day I know I was
hearing like you gotta do like two hours
a day to make like a crazy living off I
know some gamers that make like six
videos a day right by themselves but if
you're already playing video games all
day true but they feel like you
handcuffed to that you know how like
when like on YouTube if you have a
format that really hits and like you're
like oh this is tight and then after
like three years you're like or a year
you're like okay wait but I want to
other content yeah I think God in
everything it was this recent meme going
around with the kid that just won this
like video game competition it was like
three 18 year old million yeah editing
next to him they were showing all these
like professional sports like from PGA
and all that
oh we're near how much does video game
[ __ ] winner got yeah it was like a
million or maybe two and like even Tiger
Woods all the sponsors video games
rather than golf comes off as a rich
people sport they're building arenas
just for each a me now yeah not only
arenas also like I got a home I
interviewed a guy recently that is
starting a gaming gym it's a gym but
it's really just them you can train with
professions you go quick faster you tips
they give you like clues on how to you
know become a professional gamer so like
that yeah
we were just watching like drone drone
races and [ __ ] like they have this
big-ass arena [ __ ] stadium size
filled with people watch like American
Ninja Warrior obstacle course flying
drones
vr goggles yeah so they could see where
the drone is flying oh it was [ __ ]
super professional they should have
liked drone like like its build with
drones a little like projectiles and
guns and [ __ ] have them fired roll yeah
I think we already have drones that
shoot and missiles and stuff like in
real life yeah oh yeah those kill people
yeah damn it really sucks oh ho ninja
was saying how he has built his branding
and all this following for all of these
years for Twitter just be like yeah
we're gonna piggyback off that and then
this should happen yeah the fact they're
not doing it with any other gamers that
have gone offline mm-hmm that is just
him you guys are gonna do like a JK
video games channel we had one it was
called JK gamer
nobody likes gaming I mean yeah yeah so
I felt for someone and pawed like the
audience could tell - you know I we
didn't just do it for like views and
[ __ ] like we were playing but it was the
commitment cuz gaming takes a lot of
[ __ ] commitment and if it's not the
only thing you're doing man it's it's
it's ours dude yeah if people were doing
just watch me and Chia play Mortal
Kombat for like ten minutes then like
yeah that's a really picture game though
like because if you do a Stren d yeah
come on cuz I would just play for ki
Mario games all day Mario Party all
[ __ ] day link you could if you really
wanted to I guess so good night Isaac
has been toying with the idea of
starting his own gaming channel cuz he
really loves playing video games and
right now like that's his thing with
Swit throw up twitch oh [ __ ] switch and
then with the xbox and then so we even
like I even asked people on my Instagram
like do you think like shitty or should
he not and a lot of people were like
well only if he wants to and I'm like
obviously he only if you want to we're
not gonna force it but we kind of want
him cuz he wants to do this on his own
where he wants to learn how to edit and
like learn how to we got that that
device that allows you to record and
gaming and so he's really excited about
so we're like cool you take it and you
can learn and if you want to do it go
for it but obviously like we would be
monitored do you start recording and
in-game [ __ ]
so Casey and they did do a halo gameplay
blog damn and but so like it doesn't
it's not really our channel's thing so
it's his own channel so he wants to
start his own channel like we uploaded
it on our channel but just to test it
out yeah just to test it mm-hmm but
people don't really care to see gaming
on our channel so right you could do
your own thing if you want but it's just
really up in the air it's not something
that we're really looking to do yeah but
I don't know no I say you take him out
of school maybe do it full-time get that
[ __ ] poppin now yeah get it early mm-hmm
can you imagine if you get like like
Thai canal and and and or like any baby
right now and trained them to be a
[ __ ] awesome gamer by the time
they're like 18 done deal
billionaire tycoon might be able to be a
mountain climber he's good at climbing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]